[Musik]
ich gehe heute mit luise amtsberg von
den grünen ein escape room in dem sich
kriminelle gangs gegenseitig nieder am
erzählen
mit anderen worten ein kleiner harmloser
urlaub von all den problemen in der
echten welt auf die grünen zu kommen
haben sie so ein bisschen platzangst
ich habe endlich anpacken kann für sich
ja also ich nehme auf jeden fall
klaustrophobischer dann haben wir genau
den richtigen raum für sie sagt sind
hier in hong kong großartig wir sollen
jetzt ihren freund finden auf denen sie
sich all die jahre verlassen konnten und
jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr da ist an
welche partei erinnert sieht dieser
verschwundene freund ich habe mich nicht
genau wie spd ja und wir schauen uns mal
wie geht es hier weiter
was finden wir hier in diesem kleinen
räumlichen gehört das wirklich dazu
vielleicht ja soll ich das jetzt mal
hoch nehmen oder an uns damit machen
also sie könnten zum beispiel also ich
könnte mir vorstellen ohne jetzt tipps
geben zu wollen dass der dass der staub
schlüssel
sind machen können der wesentlichen also
vielleicht kann man damit ja irgendwie
eine tür aufmachen
ja okay wir können das aufbrechen oder
also jetzt nicht kriminell werden
okay das ist natürlich das heißt nicht
kriminell werden also ich kriege meine
schraubt schlossen hier nicht so und die
nicht ding einfach so auf ich müsste es
ja aufhebeln genau aber mir wurde ja
auch da sein rohe gewalt ist keine
lösung wir gehen vielleicht über die
treppe hoch aber ich finde das schon mal
dass sie bereit sind hier wirklich auch
kriminell vorzugehen und einem
kriminellen escape to so anna ich habe
es gefehlt sie fest
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und wir sind im nächsten raum dieser
raum macht mir tatsächlich bisschen
angst
die erwartung nein nein es ist also sie
sehen es ist eine table dance bar
wie stehen sie zur table dance bars ich
war ja ich glaub ich machen wenn sie es
besser wäre genauso viele männer wie
frauen an den stangen toren kommt aber
wenn ich an der stange und ohne würde
sie dass die frage kann ich jetzt nicht
nur für mich allein beantworten so viele
zuschauer mit beantworten
ich würde erstmal sagen wir wir gucken
mal wieder raus und da ist eine tür und
da ist ein schlüssel wo das schlüsse der
schlüssel schlüssel stimmt der schlüssel
sieht aber nicht wie ein schlüssel aus
es geht um etwas anderes dass wir hier
finden müssen andere ja dazu wir haben
eine buddha figur
hier sind bestimmt noch mehr branchen
boden glauben sie eigentlich an einen
gott und nennen sie ihn überhaupt gott
oder sagen sie rüber zu hören ich glaube
nicht an gott aber ich glaube ein
bisschen an robert habeck
jetzt soll ich noch eine frage zum
glauben weil sie haben gesagt ich glaube
jetzt erst mal nicht an einen gott aber
sie haben ja interessanterweise
islamwissenschaften studiert und
theologie und theologie aber es gibt
eigentlich drei wichtige männer in ihrem
leben mit jesus und robert habe wir
müssen ein bisschen auf die tube drücken
denn die zeit läuft ist sie dürfen nicht
vergessen marie agnes strack zimmermann
wird den raum auch machen
wer weiß vielleicht ist die schon längst
fertig derzeit
was ist passiert ging obwohl ich dann ja
in der table k-class okay also muss
jetzt tanzen wollen wir werden zwar
lichter erscheinen diese lichter gilt
ist zu tanzen
das heißt sie sagen mir die farbe ja ich
habe das selber noch nie gemacht
sie lassen weiter weiter so was er
gelesen panischen herstellen jeder
springt ja grün blau
jetzt sinkt doch ja das tut jetzt müssen
die agila rot grün rot grün lila blau
ist das sparen kinderfeste ich drehe
durch spannung ist das spannend jetzt
die oder violett grün lautet alles klar
doch mal die jetzt blickt es hier weil
ich oft genug richtig drauf gedrückt das
war gut jetzt passiert okay das ist
gottes wille auf die türe und wo sind
wir in einem kleinen privatraum würde
ich sagen es ist eine opium eine opium
in einer vom verstehen ja nix haben sie
nicht sagt man hat sich jetzt ja oder
nein also wenn ich würd sagen alkohol
und zigaretten die drogen die so
ziemlich jeder konsumiert kann man ja
auch mal erwähnen als du und ja also ich
hab auch schon meine erfahrung mit
pfiffen
grundsätzlich ja cannabis und auch alle
anderen drogen sind natürlich mit
vorsicht zu genießen und man braucht
eine gute jugendpolitik aber die macht
man nicht wenn man irgendwie sagt das
ist eine böse drogen und alkohol das ist
nicht ja und diese wie batterie die da
auch von den großen großen parteien
wie wird ein glück dass das alles nicht
machen muss also muss ich jetzt
irgendwas und jungen wissen also muss
ich gucke jetzt erstmal reinhard kraft
okay es sind ohne schrecken sie ein
[Musik]
jetzt sollte den raum ja volker beck
spielen aber das war den gerne also
flasche genau und sehr gut sehr gut und
sie sehen was passiert das op und koch
wir sind jetzt in einem opiumrausch
wahrscheinlich müssen wir jetzt in koppl
lösen nämlich die tür aufgeht oder soll
jetzt es geht um diese scheibe und es
geht um dieses rätsel
ich muss mal kurz der drogenrausch hält
auch nicht mehr lange an der ist
zeitlich limitiert die braucht wesen das
rätsel zu lösen
und eines dieser felder ist nicht
abgebildet sie sind fertig wenn ich das
mal sagen vielleicht das ist ja noch da
und das ist richtig und die tür hier hat
sich bewegt das heißt sie ist auch
letzter raum bekommen wahrscheinlich
jetzt in den letzten raum
ich hoffe ich bin nämlich auch nervlich
am ende wo sie haben gesehen da ist ein
schlüssel
den würde ich einfach mitnehmen oder
klar wer weiter in die bauern auch jetzt
müssen wir in schloss aufschließen durch
die drogen dann bitte ich finde ich
super mit ihren liedern mit den drogen
dass sie die alle mitgenommen haben weil
das war über außen möglich gewesen
das wissen wir nicht wir sind hier ja im
feindesland quasi oder zumindest in
gefahr
und man kann so was immer nur brauchen
wahrscheinlich um sich freizukaufen
ok schwergängig eine drogenküche aber
dann war das genau richtig wie heftig
möchten sie sich eigentlich jedes mal
übergeben wenn sie einen neuen tweet von
boris palmer lesen ich bin ihm nun
mittlerweile aber es kotzt mich
natürlich trotzdem an weil ich glaube er
nicht versteht dass er damit die
falschen klatscher kriegt und wir alle
also parteiübergreifend unter den
demokratischen parteien die
verantwortung haben derzeit und der wird
er nicht gerecht was was will er denn
damit sagen wir diesen liegt
zu dieser bahn kampagne es ist jetzt
auch ja ja das dass die gesellschaft
nicht abgebildet sieht ja in diesem
weißen endstation und da wird oder all
dies ja teilweise nicht mal waren ja
also kann ich nicht beantworten die
frage habe ich mich natürlich auch
gefragt aber ich finde dass wir da
dahinter liegt eine debatte die durch
ausgeführt wird ja also ich sag mal von
der weißen mehrheitsgesellschaft wenn
sie dann irgendwie unterrepräsentiert
das an irgendeinem winzigen punkt in
ihrem leben nichts passiert und sich
sehr häufig als weiße
mehrheitsgesellschaft dass wir irgendwo
unterrepräsentiert sind aber wenn es
dann mal so ist ja sich dann zu
beschweren ist einfach nur ja ich finde
ich sehr sehr wenig nachvollziehbar
ja endlich wieder von seiner partei der
erkennt man überhaupt keine grünen
erzählt angreifer das sind hedonisten 1
also ich bin jetzt mal würfeln wir
gucken wir mal was passiert
das gibt es doch nicht ihr seht 3 6 und
8 10
das sind 200 räumt die spd gerade von so
könnten drei sechsen eine rolle spielen
gibt es vielleicht irgendwo ein
zahlencode an natürlich dafür
irgendwelche kulturell muss kultur
sensibel sein training nein wie viel
verlangen wir nicht okay wir sind hier
unterste schublade
also sage mal mit gewalt wollen wir hier
auch so untergekommen
und wirklich also sehr sehr geballt hält
sie hätten bei diesem stoff hätte hätten
sie dem skateboard zerstört wird
aber ich hätte dann vor allem die tür
von anfang an aufgehebelt mit dem ding
und ich schon gleich zu diesem raum
gewesen bin ich da nicht dran wenn ich
sage hier sind 6 es ist komplett falsch
wenn diese kleinen hinweis geben kann
das ist total falsch total falsch ok
stuhl nee der ist kalt und heiß oder so
mein gott das ist sowas finde ich ja
wirklich eklig muss der ach so
die fässer kennen sie castor demos okay
und weil sie alles ist okay sein freund
ist tot
in säure aufgelöst ich würde sagen aber
es war noch handschuhe lasst mich euch
nochmal auf ich hab da noch mehr als sie
müssen da eventuell ran dann unseren
toten gangster freund
[Musik]
tja und schloss an ich werde verrückt
die letzten 60 sekunden laufen auf 60 59
das nicht sicher war es nicht die türen
noch 40 sekunden
der klimawandel sitzungs anderen machen
vielleicht ist es ja was ganz anderes
sehr gut 15 sekunden 10 87 passiert hier
was ist passiert was nehmen sie ruhig
die drogen mit wir brauchen sie
eigentlich nicht aber wenn sie das
privat zehn sekunden das ding verstärken
können setzen sie kennt worten total
macht nämlich ein satz ich will dass er
es hier drohen paket noch mit doch
nichts draus hier und hier gehts raus
ramsberg sie uns europäer geld durch und
hat uns gerettet aber war ja klar dass
die grünen wieder alles unterbinden was
spaß macht
wollen sie das noch mitnehmen er ist
nämlich noch mal alles klar dankeschön
wann ist nicht viel
das sind schöne bilder übrigens dann
sind sie jetzt so mit diesen drogen die
geringe ich jetzt natürlich alle zur
polizei lag und er hat mir auch nicht na
klar
gehen sie eigentlich bringen es auch
früher zu einer anderen dienststelle
na toll eigentlich wollte ich jetzt noch
eine runde spielt aber frau amtsberg hat
das ganze opium mitgenommen
naja ist ja noch genug geld da kann ich
ja noch was besorgen und ihr lasst in
der zwischenzeit mal leichter und
abonniert diesen kanal hallo ist da
jemand davon der chinesischen mafia wird
genau was kaufen
hallo hallo